[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing some
popular fan theories pertaining to
severus snape
i'm going to discuss five theories in
total some good and some bad if you
enjoyed this type of video let me know
by liking the video and leaving a
comment i've got five more ready for a
part two
let's get started
why snape never became dada professor
defense against the dark arts is a core
subject taught at hogwarts that
purportedly teaches students how to
defend themselves against dark magic
but one thing that the position is
perhaps best known for is the curse
placed upon it by tom riddle after his
application had been denied the
resulting curse meant that for as long
as the rule existed no professor would
be able to hold the position for more
than one school year
and tom was true to his word as after
cursing the role each and every
professor had their own unique reason
for leaving it
there were many different witches and
wizards that acted as dada professor
during harry's time at hogwarts
but one wizard that always wanted the
position but never got it was snape
dumbledore respected snape for the most
part and knew that he was more than
qualified for the role
so why wouldn't he have given snape what
he wanted
well the predominant theory states that
dumbledore knew the role was cursed
dumbledore knew that he wouldn't be able
to keep a data teacher for more than a
year and he knew that if he gave it to
snape that something bad might happen to
him
for these reasons he never allowed snape
to become data professor to protect him
snape is a vampire we don't see or hear
about vampires too much in the harry
potter story but we do know that they
exist in the harry potter universe
because harry meets one named sanguini
in the half blood prince
the theory i'm about to introduce you to
suggests that there was one vampire in
the story that hits much closer to home
severus snape
why is snape a vampire well his
character just so happens to possess
many of the defining characteristics of
one the first major characteristic of a
vampire that i want to touch on is
avoiding sunlight
it's well known that vampires
like some animals avoid light they have
a tendency to inhabit dark conditions
and some spend their lives in permanent
darkness
this describes snape to a t
snape's office in the dungeons of
hogwarts is described as follows
the office was a gloomy and dimly lit
room found in the school dungeons the
shadowy walls were lined with shelves of
large glass jars
filled with slimy revolting things such
as bits of animals and plants floating
in potions of varying colors snape's
office is perhaps the darkest and
deariest of all of the offices belonging
to hogwarts staff and the dimly lit
gloomy room in the dungeons of the
school seems like the perfect place for
one type of creature
a vampire
yes we have seen severus snape under
direct sunlight in his school boy days
but you can always become a vampire
later in life
he could have also figured out a way to
spend time in sunlight as we know that
he's an incredibly talented wizard and
an excellent potioneer the next
characteristic i want to discuss is
heightened senses
vampires are said to have heightened
vision hearing and sense of smell
though i don't have too many specific
examples of snape exhibiting super
heightened sensors he does seem to have
a habit of making an appearance whenever
students are breaking rules wondering
out of their common rooms when they
shouldn't be or meddling in matters that
do not relate to them i'm sure he's
always lurking around the castle at
night but he also seems to be
particularly aware of what's happening
at the castle at all times if you can
recall the night that harry wandered
into the restricted section of the
library with his invisibility cloak
you'll remember that he bumped into
snape and quirrell
even though harry was under the
invisibility cloak an extremely advanced
magical artifact snape still had a
strong intuition that someone was there
this was shown by him reaching into the
air
i think that this is a reflection of his
perhaps heightened senses
next up we have morphing or in the harry
potter world transfiguration
vampires are said to have the ability to
morph into another form like a bats
often behind the shroud of a cloak
after morphing they simply disappear
creating the illusion that they have
vanished flying away from their
aggressor
on one occasion snape does exactly this
in the deathly hallows we see snape jump
from the tower of the hogwarts castle
the following passage depicts snape
flying in front of mcgonagall harry and
some of the students
he jumped said professor mcgonagall you
mean he's dead harry sprinted to the
window
no he's not dead said mcgonagall he
seems to have learned a few tricks from
his master
what this passage suggests is that snape
flew away
rowling is reported to have stated that
all wizards have the power of flight
innately but the vast vast majority need
a broom to achieve it
in voldemort's case he was so focused
and powerful that he was able to channel
the power to fly and supported
harnessing the energy through himself
rather than the broom
maybe snape did the same but i really
think that he achieved it another way a
vampiric way
going back to the first passage where
snape jumps from the hogwarts tower
there's one line that really peaked my
interest
i think that it could shed some light on
his method of flying
harry saw a huge bat-like shape flying
through the darkness as far as the books
are concerned when voldemort uses
unsupported flight he maintains his
original form
so what's this bat-like shape why would
snape resemble a bat
my answer snape's a vampire
snape's secret message to harry this
theory is centered around severus snape
harry potter and one of their first
encounters in snape's first year potions
class
it suggests that snape may have relayed
a secret message to harry when they
first met
the moment occurred right at the
beginning of the series in harry potter
and the philosopher's stone when harry
first sits down in snape's potions class
already suspicious of snape snape makes
it very clear right away that he doesn't
like harry mocking him as hogwarts new
celebrity right before quizzing him on
the spot about different magical herbs
in spite of his fame harry had known
nothing of the wizarding world until
very recently and this meant that he had
no chance of being able to answer
snape's questions
this is something that snape undoubtedly
knew
hoping to make harry look foolish
mr potter our new celebrity
tell me what would i get if i added
powdered root of aspardelle to an
infusion of wormwood
you don't know well let's try again
where mr potter would you look if i
asked you to find me a bazaar
and what is the difference between
monkshood and wolfsbane
pity
clearly fame isn't everything is it mr
potter
at first glance all this dialogue shows
us is that snape wants to bully harry a
bit he's purposely asking harry
questions to which he does not know the
answer
however the theory that i want to
discuss suggests that snape's questions
are actually relaying a secret message
to harry however it's not a message that
he ever expected harry to understand
snape is a complex individual and the
message in question was simply for
himself
let's dissect snape's secret message
his first question to harry is what
would i get if i added powdered root of
asphadel to an infusion of wormwood
and what's curious about this is that
according to the victorian flower
language asphodel is actually a type of
lily
this lily means my regrets follow you to
the grave in the second part of snape's
question wormwood means absence which is
symbolized by sorrow
combined this could be interpreted as i
bitterly regret lily's death and this is
of course significant because lily is
harry's mother the only woman that snape
ever loved
deep right
to add to this even further snape's
question even contains an allusion to
his own death as aspardelle was once
believed to be a cure for snake bites
which of course snape eventually dies
from
or does he
snape is alive why he never died
we see what we believe to be snape dying
in the deathly hallows after voldemort
thinks that he needs to kill snape in
order to become the true owner of the
elder wand we of course later find out
that snape died in vain as he was never
the true owner of the elder wand at all
and was unnecessarily killed by
voldemort
however what was always interesting
about voldemort killing snape was that
he didn't do it himself he used nagini
it cannot be any other way said
voldemort i must master the wand severus
master the wand and i master potter at
last and voldemort swiped the air with
the elder wand it did nothing to snape
who for a split second seemed to think
he had been reprieved but then
voldemort's intention became clear the
snake's cage was rolling through the air
and before snape could do anything more
than yell it had encased him head and
shoulders and voldemort spoke in parcel
tongue
kill
there was a terrible scream harry saw
snape's face losing the little color it
had left it whitened as his black eyes
widened as the snake's fangs pierced his
neck as he failed to push the enchanted
cage off himself
as his knees gave way and he fell to the
floor
nagini killing snape rather than
voldemort using avada kadavra which
would surely end his life does actually
leave the door open a little bit
particularly as it's supposedly nagini's
venom that ends up bringing snape to his
inevitable demise
harry lifted the silvery substance into
it with his wand when the flask was full
to the brim and snape looked as though
there was no blood left in him his grip
on harry's robes slackened
look at me he whispered
the green eyes found the black but after
a second something in the depths of the
dark pair seemed to vanish
leaving them fixed blank and empty
the hand-holding harry thudded to the
floor and snape moved no more
the above passage suggests that snape
died but at the beginning of the next
chapter we should take note of the fact
that harry gets distracted almost
immediately after snape's demise
harry remained kneeling at snape's side
simply staring down at him until quite
suddenly a high cold voice spoke so
close to them that harry jumped on his
feet the flask gripped tightly in his
hands
thinking that voldemort had re-entered
the room
there are a couple of things that
support the fact that snape may not have
actually died
first of all harry didn't really stick
around to make sure that snape had died
it looked that way but this is a magical
world after all and i think that it's
definitely within the realm of
possibility for him to have survived
additionally snape's corpse was never
found or mentioned
after the battle of hogwarts
all of the bodies were accounted for
even the bodies of death eaters harry
sees the corpses of people that he knows
and loves lupine fred etc and provided
that harry knew of snape's sacrifice
it's reasonable to assume that they
would search for his body as well
snape was bitten by nagini and
presumably died from snakes venom but
one glaringly obvious issue with this is
that snape was a potions master the
likelihood that snape wouldn't know of
or carry an anti-venom is highly
unlikely particularly as he was playing
the dangerous role of a spy in the
wizarding war
snape was a smart man and would have
likely been prepared for any eventuality
nagini biting him included
so how does that explain snape's
lifeless body there's always the
possibility that the venom only
paralyzed him and placed him into a
comatose state there's plenty of snake
venom out there that does just this and
this comatose state could have easily
been confused as snape dying
harry never really examined snape after
he died so if snape had taken an
anti-venom before being bitten it may
have just taken some time for the
effects to kick in
i don't think that snape bled out either
as he'd even invented his own counter
curse that could stop blood from flowing
from the body vulnerable
another thing that could potentially
support the argument that snape never
died is the fact that harry never saw
him in the forbidden forest
when harry produces the resurrection
stone he sees the shades of his father
sirius lupin and his mother
all of these people were massively
important in harry's life the fact that
snape wasn't there could it work either
for or against the argument that he
never died here's why
first it's important to know that the
stone shows you your loved ones and
people who are massively important to
you
given that at this point harry was aware
of all the sacrifices that snape had
made you'd expect that he would show up
along with the other shades
snape protected harry for years and even
died with the ultimate goal of saving
him so you'd expect to see snape
wouldn't you
the issue with this is that snape is
just not on the same level as his
parents sirius and lupin
snape made huge sacrifices for harry yes
but harry wasn't aware of them until
very close to the time that he presented
the stone
his feelings for snape were still
settling in as he had only recently had
a change of heart about the man who
tormented him for much of his youth
additionally the stone was meant to
bring back the people that harry never
got a chance to say goodbye to and with
snape he did get this opportunity
felix felici's gone wrong
felix felicis or liquid luck is
introduced to us in the half blood
prince it's a potion that put quite
simply
enables the consumer to become
successful in all of their endeavors
professor horace slughorn potions master
of hogwarts once expressed that he had
taken liquid luck twice in his life with
each occasion resulting in a perfect day
a potion like liquid luck certainly has
an allure to it but it's also worth
mentioning that it's not very
straightforward to brew
i have no doubt in my mind that over the
centuries many successful potioneers
have tried to brew the concoction and
failed
one popular snape theory suggests that
all of snape's hardships failing to
court lily failing to become data
professor being bullied and being blamed
for dumbledore's death are all the
result of a liquid luck potion gone bad
during snape's youth
snape was an avid potioneer so there's
no question that he had tried to brew
the potion
it's also highly likely that snape had
tried and failed various methods
as he had instructions on how to brew
the perfect concoction in his own
potions textbook
i imagine this took some trial and error
could it be that snape drank a bad batch
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think of these theories if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you